bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau 7,8 week-end comme tous
les vendredis vous en avez l'habitude
nous allons revenir sur les moments
forts de l'actualité culture loisirs et
sports de la semaine pendant 26 minutes
mais tout d'abord vous le savez ce
vendredi soir aura lieu la 39e cérémonie
des césar au théâtre du châtelet à paris
et en coulisse s'activent les étudiants
de l'école audiovisuel des troisièmes de
trappes encadré évidemment par leur
responsable pédagogique qui est en ligne
avec nous de paris vincent motais ce
bonjour à vous bonjour tout d'abord cela
fait donc cinq ans que vous êtes
partenaires de l'académie des césars
quel est votre rôle tout d'abord par
rapport à cette cérémonie qui aura lieu
ce soir alors mis au travail pour la
qualité
des images qui vont aller sur leur ont
montré toutes les événements que je pour
l'académie et surtout que ce soit à moi
surtout montré tout ce qui se passe un
peu en commission infrastructure
donc on a un peu près 20 étudiants
mobilisés qui tourne un peu partout sur
les points importants tous les ans très
joli cocktail sur la salle de presse
déchire aussi le
photocall mais aussi le plus important
c'est surtout un plateau qui va vers le
deuxième derrière la scène de tout à
fait et sur lequel on va recevoir tous
les lauréats qui se maintient en 18
parties
ont pu lire l'heure leur version
j'imagine que vous êtes dans les tous
derniers préparatifs d'installation des
projecteurs des caméras
les étudiants
encore lesquels sont qu'elles sont avec
justement quel est leur état d'esprit à
vos étudiants ce moment il n'y a pas
trop de stress à quelques heures du
début la cérémonie
il faut
mais
je viens de l'un des leurs caméras
oui j'allais venir c'est vraiment un
exercice grandeur nature pour vos
étudiants il n'y aura pas le droit à
l'erreur ce soir c'est des interviews en
one-to-one il faut vraiment les réussir
du premier coup
donc ce qu'on sera prêt et ça peut
arriver à n'importe quel moment et la
foule
est absurde de l'homme n'a même pas le
temps de dire attendez ninon puisque en
une sorte de jeu de scène à une faute ou
un parcours le plateau de canal+ qui est
juste à côté nous passons sur rtl après
vente sur deux conférences de presse qui
vont donc un staff qui va très très vite
ou une gamelle
de
pouvoir
en étudiant et encadrants vous serez à
peu près une vingtaine ce soir au
théâtre du châtelet j'imagine qu'il a
fallu les sélectionner ses étudiants des
trois pièces alors oui en général on a
pas mal de temps que
plusieurs événements
et
promouvoir le cinéma donc là plusieurs
règlements et ça c'est déjà depuis un
mois depuis début janvier ce qu'on
tourne avec le suppliant événement donc
ça permet de tester pas mal d étudiants
qui a trait aux exercices pédagogiques
allaient à l'école ouais ce qui suit on
peut
compter qu'ils sont vraiment
cette soirée c'est un peu la réponse qui
travaillent
merci beaucoup vincent modestes d'avoir
pris quelques minutes je ne vous prend
pas plus de temps je sais que vous avez
encore beaucoup de choses à faire d'ici
ce soir votre produit fini sera donc
remis à l'académie des césar est
disponible sur internet une fois montés
évidemment merci beaucoup vincent à très
bientôt
la 13e édition du festival du cirque des
mureaux a accueilli ce week-end pas
moins de 46 un artiste un tas de
renommée internationale numéro revisités
ou grands classiques toutes les
tendances étaient présentes sous le
chapiteau aurélien de bissy le temps
d'un week end sous le chapiteau installé
parc du sceau tour une quarantaine
d'artistes ont paradé dans l'arène entre
disciplines traditionnelles et le numéro
moderne de festival du cirque des murs
ont créé en 2001 sous l'impulsion de la
commune est devenu l'un des plus
renommés en ile de france un mouvement
populaire et familial qui pour cette 13e
édition maintient une politique
tarifaire attractive avec des places
comprise entre 5 12 euros des artistes
venus du monde entier ont fait valoir
leur talent sous la houlette de monsieur
loyal cette année encore en charge de la
programmation la porter à un vrai un
beau spectacle de cirque à la portée de
toutes les bourses c'est à dire que les
familles n'aient plus les les moins
riches qui peuvent pas se payer des
places à 45 euros ou à 50 euros voire 60
parfois puissent voir le même spectacle
un tarif à la porte est plus parce que
le rêve appartient à tout le monde et
c'est aussi le cirque le seul endroit le
sel c'est le seul que j'appelle ça le
cercle d'amour parce que c'est le seul
endroit où il y avait une véritable
intégration et acceptation de toutes
nationalités toutes toute religion toute
mentalité quelle qu'elle soit pour la
première fois aux mureaux la troupe
eagles des artistes gabonais nous
présenter leurs spécialités
l'acrobatique ont commencé avec
de fierté de faire des savoirs que l'on
peut s'intéresser à la culture gabonaise
le cirque que cet africain peut être
exécutée avec la danse africaine de la
danse africaine peut être ouverte à
n'importe quel la numéro revisités aux
grands classiques le cirque a pour
essence de créer des émotions chez le
spectateur ou prouesse technique qui
exploite côtoient création artistique et
chorégraphique
leçons du coin lance une opération de
promotion de la scène locale une
démarche de soutien à la campagne vote
ont plus de musique dans nos villes en
2014 évidemment par rapport aux
élections municipales cette semaine dans
kiosque aurélia de bissy a reçu cyril
vermander créateur et administrateur de
ce site internet
toutes les formes d'écouté de pratique
musicale connaissent un véritable
engouement ces dernières années
toutefois on peut noter que les
structures les lieux de diffusion des
salles les écoles de musique les studios
de répétition viennent à manquer parfois
dans certaines villes on peut même
parent parler de désert musicaux donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
acteurs du rif alors le rif c'est le
réseau de musique en ile de france se
mobilise pour que les enjeux liés aux
musiques actuelles soient présentes dans
le cadre des élections municipales on
est en plein dedans en ce moment et
c'est comme ça que la campagne votons
plus de musique dans nos villes en 2014
est lancé vous soutenez cette démarche
cheryl oui complètement
alors ben en fait
je propose donc sur le son du point un
album à télécharger gratuitement donc en
mp3 d'artistes inscrits sur le site et
pour vous faire la promotion de des
artistes des artistes indépendants de la
région parce que dans cette campagne on
parle beaucoup de studios de répétition
de talent de ce concert de subventions
mais je trouvais ça bien de remettre un
peu de musique dans ce débat de montrer
quels sont les artistes qui vont
utiliser les studios de répétition
qu'elles sont des artistes qui vont se
produire sur ces scènes sur ces scènes
municipal et donc voilà de présenter de
présenter la scène locale sous forme de
dons album à télécharger gratuitement
j'aimerais qu'on viennent justement sur
l'histoire du site quel est son principe
voilà son fonctionnement alors le
principe ça fonctionne comme comme une
plateforme de streaming comme on peut en
voir beaucoup en ce moment
mais il va il est dédié aux artistes
locaux donc il ad'abord et ouvrir dans
les yvelines et maintenant ils s'ouvrent
à plusieurs départements donc le but
étant de couvrir les artistes d'île de
france pour faire une promotion sur les
artistes les artistes locaux par ville
pour que chacun puisse voir qu'est ce
qu'il ya dans sa ville d'où viennent
d'où viennent les artistes
qu'ils aiment bien d'où vient un artiste
qui veut qui peut voir jouer dans sa mjc
donc ça c'est visiteurs mais visiteurs
il vient il clique il ya une
géolocalisation c'est ce principe de la
sélection par bing donc on a été un
concert dans une salle de sa ville et
puis on va retrouver le groupe à
proximité et via des suggestions on peut
aussi découvrir d'autres groupes qui
viennent de la ville d'à côté où les
artistes
quels avantages bas celle inverse du
coup puisque le site s'adresse à un
public essentiellement locale donc c'est
un public qui va se déplacer pour les
voir en concert ou acheter leurs albums
l'inconvénient des grosses plateformes
comme deezer ou spotify par exemple
c'est qu'on est noyé dans la masse des
artistes internationaux et même si c'est
bien aussi d'avoir une visibilité
internationale s'est pas forcément des
artistes qui vont s'engager donc là on
s'adresse vraiment un petit local et le
site est gratuit et est aussi avocat
consulté par les programmateurs et les
professionnels de la région et qui vont
faire aussi leur marché quand ils ont
besoin d'un groupe local ou vitrines
s'accroît donc la visibilité et du coup
ça nous promet une promotion vraiment
ciblées voilà c'est cela combien pour
avoir quelques chiffres combien d'euros
alors pour l'instant un peu plus de 400
groupes principalement sur les civils
mais aussi douce que les deux autres
départements
qui sont au vert c'est le val d'oise et
l'essonne sont ouverts depuis début
janvier donc ça commence un petit à
petit mais donc plus de 400 groupes sur
un sur deux départements
la serre aux papillons de la
queue-lez-yvelines entame sa nouvelle
saison une quarantaine d'espèces volts
en liberté dans un climat de forêt
amazonienne l'occasion de voyager de
partir à la découverte de ces insectes
éphémère et mystérieux violaine thorez
les observer pour nous
nous voici dans la jungle équatoriale de
la queue-lez-yvelines plus de 7 100
papillon vole en liberté parmi les
visiteurs on les reçoit des philippines
du costa rica de guyane martinique on
les reçoit donc en chrysalide et les
chrysalides font installer ensuite dans
les esclops voir et à partir de ses
épaules voire les papillons naisse le
matin une fois qu'ils sont nés ils
déploient leurs ailes entre 30 minutes
et deux heures selon les variétés les
papillons sont ensuite libéré et se
nourrissent naturellement de plantes
mais pas seulement la seule chose qu'on
a alors à leur apporter c'est des
compléments de nourriture parce que
comme il ya beaucoup de papillons les
fleurs des prés ça se fit pas assez donc
on leur met des tubes sur des fleurs
artificielles avec de l'eau sucrée et
certaines variétés se nourrissent de
fruits en fermentation donc on leur met
des assiettes avec des bananes pourries
dans un climat de forêt amazonienne avec
28 degrés et 80 % d'humidité certains
photographes voyage à travers leurs
clichés ya une majorité de papillons
d'amérique du sud des espèces qu'on voit
pas en france
c'est très agréable à regarder et à
photographier difficile au niveau
technique que ma photo c'est ça un bon
exercice
les papillons c'est une merveille de la
nature et on est il faut est capable de
justement de pouvoir apprécier ce que ce
qu'ils aient donné d'une manière adulte
adultes les papillons vivent en moyenne
trois semaines et sans son nouveau sont
apportés chaque semaine pour renouveler
la certes
je suis sûr que étant enfant vous avez
tous rêvé au moins un jour d'avoir des
pouvoirs extraordinaires pendant une
semaine l'estaminet à magny les hameaux
a invité les enfants à façonner leur
costume de super héros selon leur
imagination
violaine thorez et elodie moines
qui n'a pas rêvé d'avoir des pouvoirs
extraordinaires pendant une semaine
l'estaminet à manille les amours invité
les enfants à façonner leur costume de
super héros selon leur imagination
ils ont dessiné les différents éléments
du déguisement on m'avait demandé du
coup de venir faire une semaine de
création de costumes de super-héros en
essayant de changer un petit peu les
codes de super héros pas forcément venir
faire le costume de batman de spider man
ou voilà mais plutôt de s'approprier le
super héros à soi les enfants ont appris
les bases de la couture ils sont prêts à
rééditer cette expérience chez eux
mêmes parce qu'après
maintenant matin je pourrais le refaire
et c'est bien de le refaire comme ça on
pourra le donner à quelqu'un d'autre est
criard l approche de mardi gras les
enfants pourront jouer les apprentis
justicier avec leurs propres costumes
très beaux costumes allez on passe aux
sports pour terminer ce journal ce lundi
dans le 7-8 sport nous vous diffusions
une interview exclusive du nouveau
phénomène des templiers shelton de
jeunes quarterbacks américain de 22 ans
arrivé à l'intersaison pourquoi at il
choisi elancourt sa passion pour le foot
us et ses ambitions il s'est livré au
micro de jonathan milman elodie moines
pourquoi as tu choisi ils ont cours
à tsavo
wen
jiabao
vous savez j'avais plus d'options quand
j'ai vu le pourtour venir ici en france
concernant l encours j'ai discuté avec
l'entraîneur manu charest et je me suis
aperçu qu'il y avait une grosse
différence entre elancourt et les autres
équipes françaises
elles en cours l'objectif prioritaire
est de gagner le championnat tout le
monde est tourné vers cet objectif tout
le monde ici veut ce titre chez les
autres on me disait on espère faire une
belle saison et être compétitif voilà la
grande différence entre elles en cours
et les autres équipes
concrètement quels sont tes objectifs
cette saison avec les templiers gagner
le championnat français
je n'ai pas vraiment d'objectif
personnel je n'en ai jamais en vérité je
veux juste gagner les huit matches du
championnat c'est le plus important je
pense que tout le monde serait déçu si
on ne gagne pas le championnat et moi
aussi
tu sais que tu passes derrière vini roth
c'est un beau challenge de lui succéder
à la
wii ce que j'ai entendu sur lui c'est
que c'est un super mec mais c'est aussi
un super quarterbacks qui était tout
près de devenir le meilleur joueur du
championnat je comprends qu'il est était
un joueur phare du championnat je sais
que j'ai une grande responsabilité pour
relever sa succession ici et améliorer
ce qu'il a déjà fait pour toi il
encourait une étape dans sa progression
oui quand je jouais à l'université je
disais souvent que je voulais continuer
de jouer autant que possible et ici
c'est une nouvelle expérience pour moi
c'est vraiment l'occasion pour moi de
progresser pas seulement en tant que
joueur mais aussi en tant qu'entraîneur
communiquer avec les gens malgré la
barrière de la langue et c'est un gros
défi pour un entraîneur
et
un la zacop une dernière question est ce
que tu te plais à elancourt
oui oui c'est tellement différent de
tout ce que j'ai connus auparavant
je suis vraiment heureux ici et j'essaie
de devenir un bon français a
et b exposé
c'est une superbe expérience personnelle
sur de nombreux plans hockey fun ce lot
shine
il est le plus vieux joueur de rugby de
france à 74 ans philippe wallraff jouer
avec l'équipe loisirs du sky rugby
malgré la polémique sur l'âge limite des
joueurs toute récente la petite star des
troubadours compte bien encore inscrire
quelques essais avant de raccrocher les
crampons
philippe val rave est un costaud
douzième enfant d'une famille de
maréchaux ferrants nordistes à 74 ans ce
deuxième ligne de l'équipe loisirs des
troubadours ne joue quasiment jamais une
rencontre
et pourtant lorsqu'il découvre le rugby
à l'âge de 20 ans l'ovalie ne lui parlez
pas trop je ne comprenais rien à ce jeu
ils m'ont amené là ils mendient banque
mellat pour une touche tu sautes tu
prends la balle j'ai sauté j'ai pris la
baguette et partez pas malhabile qui
nous plaît pu m'entraîner de plus rester
dans le rugby depuis la sphère francis
baiona ce pilier de 68 ans privé de
licence en raison de son âge trop avancé
tous les regards se tournent vers access
pas d'inquiétude pour autant car tous
les ans son médecin signe la licence de
cet ancien ingénieur les yeux fermés mon
médecin qui est de montigny est un
excellent médecin m'a bien dit bon
philippe tu continues mais fait quand
même attention parce que
non tu prends des risques mais tant que
les avantages sont dépasse largement les
risques et à moi ne pas prendre trop de
risques donc c'est une question de
précaution faut juste le voir pour le
voir pour le croire quoi 74 ans est à
fond comme ça j'avoue que je sais pas si
j'y serai comme et puis chaque fois que
tu le tout le temps point d'un petit peu
c'est cesser c'est le genre de mec à
dire attendez les gars je parle bibelots
quoi il n'y a pas de problème à les y
quoi c'est comme ça quoi la saison
dernière avec sa licence toujours
tamponné compétition il a même joué 20
minutes avec la réserve du sky rugby en
championnat d'honneur mais il y a deux
ans un adversaire le plaquent assez
violemment ramsès reste ko ça m'a fait
très peur donc maintenant je joue proche
des gros l'apprend des chocs en face ça
me fait pas peur mais je fais plus le
jeu peut pas le mariole toujours un peu
dans les affaires où mon généreux du
club ce joueur pas comme les autres
organisera un grand tournoi l'an
prochain en dordogne où il possède une
bicoque qu'il retape pour ses vieux
jours à sa sortie du prix
et on espère tous évidemment faire du
sport encore à ces pages ce week-end
avait lieu la 5e édition de l'ipl
concours international d'aéromodélisme
assez traditionnel aux clayes-sous-bois
les pilotes et leurs maquettes ont
encore proposer des prestations
spectaculaires que ce soit en figures
imposées ou en veulent libres avec
musique olivier maniscalco a levé les
yeux
nouvel envol pour l'eee top aux
clayes-sous-bois pour sa cinquième et
dernière édition la compétition
internationale d'aéromodélisme a encore
une fois réuni les meilleurs pilotes
mondiaux très spectaculaire les
démonstrations de voltige ont offert un
show impressionnant les modélistes été
jugé à la fois sur l'épreuve des figures
imposées ou le jury note que la qualité
technique et la géométrie mais aussi sur
du vol en musique où les pilotes
proposent un véritable ballet aérien un
pilotage exigeant qui requiert certaines
aptitudes il faut avoir de bons réflexes
d'excellents réflexes parce que de temps
en temps mais l'avion va pas faire
exactement ce qu'il faut donc il faut
avoir des très bons réflexes à la
télécommande
mais c'est surtout une question
d'entraînement à force de faire et puis
surtout savoir construire aussi
parce que souvent ça casse donc il faut
savoir reconstruire les maquettes
fabriqué en plaques de d'éperons et en
papier millar matériaux qui servent
d'habitude à l'isolation de nos maisons
font un peu moins d'un mètre d'envergure
pour un poids qui varie entre 50 et 100
g des mesures peaufiné durant la
construction des modèles réduits ou le
moindre réglage compte c'est
principalement des changements de forme
sur l'avion des
des améliorations de répartition de
surface est toujours essayé de gagner du
poids parce qu'on indoor plus on est
déviée mieux ça veulent mon avion on va
dire sur le panel ici est assez lourd il
fait 80 g mais il est aussi relativement
grand c'est un des plus grands du
circuit
65 participants représentant 15
nationalités différentes concourait lors
de cet eee top 2014 six français ont
terminé dans le top 10
c'était en quelque sorte le match de la
dernière chance près de 80 ans après
leur dernier succès en championnat les
féminines de l'entente nationale
versailles se sont imposé le week-end
dernier face à rennes et reste donc
encore en vie dans cette poule de
nationale une de basket résumé
sur le parquet du gymnase b l'air
soufflé comme un air de survie les
féminines de l'entente le chesnay
versailles n'avaient pas le droit à
l'erreur face à rennes en mode commando
les yvelinoises entame parfaitement la
rencontre menée par une cécile dansèrent
impérial dans la raquette qui a usé la
défense adverse et auteur de 17 points
27 14 après le premier quart temps mais
le deuxième acte sera celui des
rennaises comme souvent cette saison les
yvelines la voix leur matelas diminué
pour rentrer aux vestiaires avec trois
petits points d'avance 35 32 les
coéquipières de virginie aurensan entame
le dernier quart temps le panier dans le
viseur et reprennent 14 points d'avance
les illinoise avaient l'occasion de
terminer la rencontre en roue libre mais
c'était sans compter sur la révolte des
rennaises qui au prix d'un bel effort
recoller à deux petits points deux
minutes du buzzer avant que melanie b ne
prenne ses responsabilités
les yvelinois s'impose finalement
71-64 reste 11e de leur poule et
retrouve la victoire près de quatre mois
après leur dernier succès l'opération
commando a fonctionné dur et long comme
tous leurs matches depuis le début
d'année on a perdu 80% de nomad 88
points toujours sur le même scénario là
on a tenu le match du début à la fin
avec un très beau premier quart temps
c'est ce qui est important de 27 points
à deuxième carton beaucoup taux moyens
légaux on a les filles ont fait le
travail ce soir et c'est très bien on
est en mode commando sur tous les matchs
maintenant et s'est passé ce soir voilà
on a mis les lancers francs alors que
d'habitude on méconnaît lancers francs
on a provoqué un petit peu la chance
c'était très bien
on termine ce journal par votre achat
d'un du week-end est tout d'abord de
rendez vous à ne pas rater du football
américain ce samedi 1er mars premier
match des templiers d'elancourt à
domicile face aux molosses d'asnières
coup d'envoi à 20 heures au complexe
sportif dimanche à partir de 10 heures
30 les enfants vont pouvoir découvrir le
parcours du lait à la ferme pédagogique
de la base de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines en commençant évidemment par
la traite des vaches un atelier payant
de 4 euros pour les enfants
c'est la fin de cette édition merci
encore une fois de l'avoir suivi je vous
souhaite un excellent week-end sur tv
fille